My real name is Dr. David Adamovich.
My stage name is "The Great Throwdini".
I've been throwing knives for 13 years.
I started at the age of 50 and I'm 63 now.
I'm in the Guinness World Records books for three records for the speed of my throwing.
In one record, I threw 102 knives around a girl in one minute.
In another record, I threw ten knives on one side in 4.29 seconds.
And in the other record, I threw ten knives alternating on each side of the girl in four seconds.
Good Lord!
Thank you!
What does it feel like to have knives thrown at me at such high speeds?
It's alright as long as you don't move.
I'm involved in sideshow.
So, this is just another trick up my sleeve.
I don't get scared, I don't flinch.
I deal with a lot of blades and dangerous things.
It's just wonderful to see myself in the Guinness World Records books for those three records...
...and to be known around the world as the world's fastest knife thrower.